americans generate  254 million tons of trash every year so  why don't we just dump all that trash  into a volcano and have it burn up it  sounds great on paper but let me tell  you why it's a terrible idea first of  all it would be nearly impossible to  find the perfect volcano for this kind  of job and even if we were to get lucky  enough there'd still be some issues you  see lava lakes are incredibly unstable  so if you pierce their surface with  something cold like trash you'd trigger  a chain reaction of explosions and  acidic steam so if you threw thousands  of pounds of trash into these lava lakes  they would produce a massive explosion  and not to mention all the pollution  you'd create from burning this much  trash  let's just recycle more instead did you  know